[Music]
it's really easy in sort of the world of
marketing in general to sort of fall
fall victim to the shiny object syndrome
right of like innovation for the sake of
innovation and disruption for the sake
of disruption they think both of those
concepts are ultimately pretty bad for
society
you know innovation and disruption for
the sake of innovation and disruption is
like driving a wrecking ball blindfolded
right unless there's some real reason
and mission and goal for turning an
industry upside down you know if our
only goal is turning one dollar into two
or ten I'm not sure that's sufficient
motivation to upend an economy right
sometimes innovation and disruption are
necessary for progress they're necessary
for rethinking things and for getting
out of stale habits that aren't working
but I think when it comes especially
when it comes to technology relative to
social good and politics and having a
clear understanding of the communities
that you're engaging and a clear mission
that you're talking about about the role
that people are going to have in the
mission that you're trying to drive is
much more important than any particular
technical innovation using new tools is
a good idea reaching people in ways and
reaching people where they are reaching
communities where they're comfortable
and in their own language and listening
on those platforms and in those networks
where people are these are all things
that we should do right but the goal
here isn't to do something new the goal
is the same as it's always been which is
to build a relationship with a person
that sees our vision for the future or
an issue or the country the same way we
do and to inspire in them a desire to
participate in the future that we're
trying to lay out right in that we're
trying to lead and I think this is where
you know there's a real challenge in in
a world where attention is so divided
right where we consume so much content
from so many places if we are too quick
to skip to tactical conversations or in
politics to too quickly to skip the
policy so I hear that you have anxiety
about the future of your job I have a
thirty nine point plan
right when we're too quick to skip past
the emotion of anxiety and the need for
that person to feel comfortable and
confident in that we understand the
anxiety that they feel we lose track of
people really fast and I think that's a
place where President Trump was
extremely successful in 2016 right he
spoke to a frustration and anxiety about
the pace of change that was that scares
people and that scared and and it's
disruptive to all of us right the pace
of innovation is so fast that we are all
living through more disruption and more
change than we've ever had to before and
speaking to that anxiety and uncertainty
is a really important part of leadership
right leading a community through change
is about confidence and managing anxiety
and managing change and I think skipping
- I think ultimately the promises that
President Trump made during the campaign
are ones that he can't deliver on I
think they're ultimately you know he's a
little bit like a seventh grader running
for class president saying he's gonna
put coca-cola and lar fountains but he's
speaking to a feeling and an intensity
and an emotion that is important and not
speaking at that altitude we about
values and belief is is a real deficit
for progressives I think
[Music]